ces petits scientifiques en herbe sont
en train de fabriquer leur propre pain
pour observer par la suite l'effet de la
levure
cet atelier s'inscrit dans le cadre de
la manifestation la science et du goût
organisée par la ville de guyancourt
tout et sciences dans notre quotidien et
l'idée c'est de donner un regard
scientifique un peu différent par
rapport à aborder cette thématique avec
les enfants de façon ludique et
interactive
pendant une heure et demie ses enfants
âgés de 4 à 10 ans ont pu notamment
analyser différents types de champignons
j'applique pas mal de champions aussi
j'applique il ya des champignons qui
transforme des insectes un zombie autre
apprentissage pour ces scientifiques
d'un jour les propriétés de la levure la
levure relâche du gaz donc ce gaz on va
pouvoir l'observer ce qui va être
capturé donc dans un ballon et donc on
va pouvoir voir ce ballon grossir de
plus en plus pour voir justement que ce
sont des êtres vivants objectifs de
l'atelier rendre plus accessible et
ludique cette thématique des levures et
moisissures
chacun a pu apprendre à fabriquer son
pain
[Musique]
petit doute pour meliana et pauline sur
le nombre de cuillères de farine
en revanche du côté dylan et de josiah
on en est déjà à l'étape du pétrissage
on est mis de la farine du sucre
on a aussi mis du sel
chaque enfant est reparti avec son petit
pain et quelques notions scientifiques
en plus